we don't drink tea like what do you
think about honestly I think I tea is
their beautiful man I'm just a
hot-blooded American you know I brought
I prefer coffee I think I love tea I
drink it every day drinks juice this
looks like a pool in Brooklyn any cheers
Cheers
it's exciting it's lightly bitter very
earthy undertones I like you kind of
rising when you had tea parties when
you're younger and I would see mr. Gibbs
is this like antioxidants is particle
free digestive system yo Japanese people
know a lot of stuff
Who I am liking what I see here also has
a lot of milk hey comes the bubble guts
you're lactose intolerant I think so dog
but it's all good
that's so good I don't know if I like
this you don't like it it's really sweet
and I love it the texture this actually
kind of reminds me of the Scottie is it
work the consequence yeah
Rhett's love their tea I'm weeded two
men we dumped it all in a harbor now we
like coffee cheerio cheerio tips help
I'm so glad I didn't realize it mindless
muffin until you meant I felt like I'm
natural like bagel unnatural bagel the
ones that grow like on the bagel tree
one thing about Brits is they have weird
names like clotted cream did you just
eat a mouthful of balls
it's so good it's also like a fun
activity I do not expect them to be the
texture smell it
I should go free gummy bear that's a
ball I think that this would be great on
a date I disagree you guys try something
new drink some tea take it easy on the
milk y'all gonna have black tea before
give her up like pee you had that black
there class leader